[Music]
[Music]
jovian de luxembourg
commission
hello
my name is beatrice i am 10 years old i
have a little sister isabella who is six
years old i love christmas decorating
decorating and i like listening to music
today is world children's day what does
it mean to you what does the european
union do for children
well beatrice and kaizen you know you
are our future the children are the
future of europe
and the european union is very much
committed to prepare your future to work
for the children of today that they have
a good job a good education a good life
for europe we have launched now what we
call a ueu strategy
on the rights of the child
because children have rights you have
the right to go to school you have the
right to be listened to you have the
right
uh on for good health so a lot of things
are in this strategy by the way here is
a
booklet on your right so you can read it
and see how important it is
and
we also work a lot on especially on for
those children who are in more difficult
situation
you go to school you have nice moments
with your parents going to restaurants
or having nice food in the morning
unfortunately there are millions of
children in europe who do not have these
rights who do not have
a nice breakfast so we have to make sure
that every child in europe gets the same
right
the same opportunity the same good food
that they can prosper that they can
also have a good future a good job a
good education so that's called the
child guarantee so we want to guarantee
to every european child this good future
that's what we are doing and this was
launched and now we work with member
states with a lot of people to make this
real and to make it happen
what does it guarantee how will this
help my friends at
school well
uh
it
guarantees as i said already first
for those children in need those
children coming from poor families where
parents cannot afford all the things
that
when they are small that they get the
right care the right child care
in order to prepare them for school and
when they go to school
that they have the books because
books are important but not just the
books we have now seen with a pandemic
you need a computer for instance
otherwise you cannot communicate so
that's what we want to
make sure that every child gets this but
also when you
uh with your school you go somewhere you
are on a school trip
there might be some children having not
the means not having the resources to go
on school trips so to make sure that
also every child has these possibilities
when are the children in need going to
get all these things will this be for
everybody
well
i would say
as soon as possible we launched this
we also have this will cost some money
you know we have to fund this we have to
find the money to do that and so we have
european money we also convince
member states to
to give more money for children for all
these projects for all these
improvements in children's life
and we have started to do that and i
hope that
the first improvements will be come very
soon you have asked me a few questions
but now
i would like to ask you a question
if you had one wish that you would like
the european union to help you with what
would it be
help
build a study room in every primary
school with books paper tablets and more
and to have decent good and enough food
in every school
you kaisen that more and more schools
adopt mario montessori's teaching
philosophy because children should be
more autonomous in their learning
journey
these are very important wishes
we try to make them real
[Music]